moving on for the moment the judge that
Donald Trump requested to review
documents seized from his home at
Mar-A-Lago seized by the FBI that is
that judge is questioning the former
president's claims the judge held the
first hearing with lawyers from both
sides in Brooklyn New York yesterday and
Scott McFarland is following it all for
us from outside the justice department
in Washington D.C Scott good morning
Tony good morning to you it's only been
a week since Judge Raymond Deary was
named special Master but yesterday he
was already demanding answers the
central issue here are the
classification markings on the seized
records and whether the former president
ordered any of those documents
Declassified judge Deary pressed the
Trump legal team on that issue and
whether they had any evidence of
declassification and the attorneys
declined to answer arguing to do so
would complicate their defense if there
was to be a criminal indictment in this
case Deary seemed to push back saying
you can't have your cake and eat it the
Department of Justice investigation into
those seized records is paused until the
special Master concludes his work the
deadline is November 30th and overnight
more illegal filings the Department of
Justice back in court arguing that the
refusal to answer questions by team
Trump is delaying an investigation the
agents very much want to resume
Gail got it Scott we thank you